Digamos que este rectángulo verde justo aquí tiene
una área de 268 unidades cuadradas, cualesquiera
que sean esas unidades puedes imaginar que son
centímetros cuadrados o si imaginas que este es
un gran campo que estás mirando desde el espacio
podrían ser kilómetros cuadrados o algo así. Así
que sólo escribiré unidades cuadradas, y digamos
que conoces las dimensiones de un lado del campo,
digamos que conoces esto, digamos que conoces
la longitud de este lado del campo y es de 2
unidades. Y realmente no lo he dibujado a
escala, si quisiera dibujarlo a escala sería
mucho más corto, sería así, pero entonces tendría
problemas para ver el rectángulo. Supongamos que
son 2 unidades, entonces, si sabes que el área
completa es de 268 unidades cuadradas y un lado
mide 2 unidades, ¿cuánto medirá el otro lado?
Permíteme elegir otro color. ¿Cuánto mide este
lado del rectángulo, de este campo sea lo que
sea?, ¿cuál es la longitud de ese lado? Bueno,
si multiplicas estos dos lados obtienes el área,
así que si comienzas con el área, si comienzas
con 268 y divides entre el otro lado, obtendrás
la longitud de este lado justo aquí. Entonces,
si queremos calcular la longitud de ese lado
sería 268 ÷ 2. Y ya hemos visto múltiples formas
de calcular cuánto es 268 ÷ 2, pero la razón por
la que dibujé este rectángulo, o una vista aérea
de este campo o como lo quieras llamar, es para
que lo visualicemos usando el área. Entonces,
una forma de hacerlo es dividir esta área de
268 unidades cuadradas en áreas que sea más
fácil imaginar dividirlas por 2. Así que aquí
tengo el mismo campo pero lo acabo de dividir,
es el mismo campo, esta dimensión de aquí sigue
siendo 2 unidades, dos unidades pero lo dividí,
esta área azul es 200. Permíteme usar otro color.
Entonces esta área azul es de 200 unidades,
esta área amarilla es de 60 unidades y
esta área magenta es de 8 unidades. Ahora,
¿por qué es útil hacer esto? Bueno, ahora es
mucho más fácil dividir cada uno de estos entre 2;
todo lo que hice fue tomar el 268 y dije "Bueno,
mira, esto es lo mismo que 200 + 6 + 8, acabo
de dividir el 268 en cosas que son más fáciles
de dividir entre 2". Y ahora puedo tomar estas
cosas y dividirlas entre 2, puedo tomar cada
uno de ellos y dividirlos entre 2. Entonces,
¿qué es esto?, ¿cuánto va a medir este lado? Voy
a dibujarlo en un color diferente. ¿Cuánto medirá
este lado? Bueno, dos veces esto será 200, y
¿cómo lo obtuvimos? Bueno, dividimos 200 / 2,
200 ÷ 2 es 100. ¿Cuánto es 60 ÷ 2? Bueno, 60 ÷ 2
va a ser 30, esta parte del campo va a tener 30 en
esa dirección y 2 en esta dirección. Y una vez más
no lo he dibujado a escala. Y luego, finalmente,
¿cuánto medirá esta sección? Va a ser 8 ÷ 2 que es
4. Fíjate: 100 x 2 son 200, 30 x 2 son 60, 4 x 2
son 8, y entonces toda esta longitud aquí arriba
va a ser 100 + 30 + 4 o 134. Ahora, ya hemos
visto otras formas de pensar en esto, puedes decir
"Mira, 2 centenas divididas entre 2 es 1 centena,
6 decenas divididas entre 2 son 3 decenas, 8
unidades divididas entre 2 son 4 unidades". Y eso
es exactamente lo que acabamos de hacer aquí, pero
lo visualizamos usando este tipo de rectángulo,
dividiéndolo en partes que quizás sean más
fáciles de dividir entre 2. Lo dividimos en 200,
en 6 decenas o 60 y en 8 dividimos el área,
y luego tomamos cada una de esas áreas y las
dividimos entre 2 para encontrar esa parte de la
longitud. De manera que cuando las sumamos todas,
obtenemos el total, obtenemos la longitud
completa. Esta es una forma de calcularlo:
tomamos cada uno de los valores posicionales y
dividimos el campo o el rectángulo de esta manera.
Pero puedes hacerlo de otras formas, no siempre
tienes que dividirlo tanto. Por ejemplo, digamos
que esta área es de 856 unidades cuadradas,
y ahora digamos que esta longitud o este lado
de aquí mide 8 unidades, entonces ¿cómo podemos
dividir esto para que sea más sencillo calcular
el otro lado o la otra longitud? Bueno, de nuevo
856 ÷ 8 es esta longitud, podemos dividirlo entre
8 centenas, 5 decenas y 6 unidades; y puedes notar
que 5 decenas no es tan fácil de dividir entre 8,
pero podemos dividir 56 entre 8. Sabemos que 8 x
7 son 56, entonces lo que podemos hacer es dividir
este rectángulo de 856 unidades cuadradas en 800
unidades cuadradas y luego en otras 56 unidades
cuadradas, así que una vez más lo dividimos en 8
centenas y luego en 56 unidades. Es la misma área,
sólo las segmenté. Y, ahora, si dices "Mira, esto
de aquí mide 8, ¿cuál será esta longitud?" Bueno,
será 800 ÷ 8, entonces 800 ÷ 8 va a ser igual a
100. ¿Cómo calculé eso? Bueno, 800 ÷ 8 es 100,
y luego tenemos esta otra parte magenta.
¿Cuánto será 56 dividido entre 8? Bueno,
es 7, 56 / 8 es 7, entonces ¿cuál es esta longitud
total? Va a ser 100 + 7, que es igual a 107. Así
que una vez más podrías haber dicho "Mira, 8
cabe en 800 100 veces, 8 cabe en 56 7 veces,
107". Y quizá te preguntes ¿para qué sirven
estos rectángulos? Bueno, sólo para que nos
ayuden a visualizar y decir "Mira, este es un
problema de área". Si esta es el área total,
si 856 es el área total y 8 es una de las
dimensiones, entonces el otro lado o la otra
dimensión será 856 ÷ 8. Y de alguna manera,
cuando divides esto en valores posicionales,
estás dividiendo los números en partes que son más
fáciles de dividir entre 8. Puedes pensar en ello
como si estuvieras dividiendo esa área y estás
tratando de calcular partes de esta longitud,
así que esto es 100 y luego esto de aquí
es 7. De cualquier manera, espero que esto
te ayude a ampliar tus habilidades de
visualización cuando estés dividiendo.